Speaker 1: If you're already concerned about
the direction of the United States, I don't
know that today's program is going to make you
feel that much better. We had two major rallies
in the United States this weekend. Each more
depraved than the last we had the March for Life
anti-abortion rally, which we're going to get to.
We also had the anti-vaccine defeat the mandate's
rally in Washington, DC, and this rally was
headlined. And this makes me really sad because I
know the guy. Very nice guy in private. Not a dumb
guy. Robert F. Kennedy Jr., who is, some of, you
know, I've had dinner with in a small group and
and is someone that through environmental lawyers
I know is kind of in my circle. Robert F. Kennedy
Jr. headlining the defeat, the mandate's rally in
Washington, DC and saying that vaccine mandates
are worse than the Nazi Holocaust. I mean,
this really is tough to watch. The context of
this rally before we get to the clip is that these
this was supposedly an anti mandate rally, not an
anti-vax rally, but a lot of the people there are
historically anti-vax. Robert F. Kennedy Jr. At
one point I tuned in and there was a woman talking
about vaccines causing autism. I mean, for all
the claims that they're only against the mandates,
it was all of the typical anti-vax
stuff. Dr. Robert Malone was there.
Dr. Peter McCullough, sort of a who's who of Joe
Rogan guests. And I'm going to play this clip
for you. And it's this is maybe one of the most
disgusting things I've seen. And it's particularly
disturbing because this is a guy I know
who I had dinner with once and you seemed
completely connected to reality. So here is
Robert F. Kennedy Jr. Listen to this this
clip going viral yesterday? Take a look.
Speaker 2: Even in Hitler's Germany,
you could you could cross the Alps to Switzerland,
you can hide in an attic like Anne Frank did.
I visited in 1962 East Germany with my father and
met people who had climbed the wall and escaped
what was positive on me. I drew it, but it was
possible. Today the mechanisms are being put
in place. I will make its anonymous can run and.
Speaker 1: This is absolutely unconscionable and
disgusting now. It's also historically inaccurate
in the sense that. They got Anne Frank and her
family and killed her. So she was only eve-
even if you concede the completely disgusting,
vile trivialization of the Holocaust and you,
you know, you put aside 10 different things.
They got Anne Frank and Frank couldn't hide at
the end of the day. They got her and they got
her family and they killed her. But what is the
obsession here with trivializing the trauma of the
Holocaust vaccine requirements to get your kid in
school? Ah, like when the Nazis killed the Jews,
conducted disgusting medical experiments on
them, imprison them in work camps, gassed Jews.
That's like when a school says for everybody's
safety, little Joey's got to get a few vaccines.
And there was a very good tweet from the
Auschwitz Memorial Museum account saying quote
exploiting of the tragedy of people who suffered
were humiliated, tortured and murdered by the
totalitarian regime of Nazi Germany, including
children like Anne Frank in a debate about
vaccines and limitations during global pandemic
is a sad symptom of moral and intellectual decay
and understand that Bobby Kennedy is not even
just exploiting the tragedy of the Holocaust.
He's saying it wasn't as bad as what's
quote happening to them now, and of course,
nothing is happening. Now I want to play a
couple other parts of this. Let me just play
it and then I'll comment, because there's also
some other interpretation that interpretations,
there's some other aspects to this.
Speaker 2: All right. They
within five years, we're going to see for
one hundred and fifteen thousand low orbit
satellites. Wait, what? Bill Gates, as
his sixty five thousand satellites alone,
will be able to look at every square
inch of the planet 24 hours a day.
Speaker 1: We already can, by the way,
Speaker 2: they're putting in 5G
to harvest our data and control our behavior
digital currency that will allow them to punish
us from a distance and cut off our food supply.
Speaker 1:
So it's like he goes into other conspiracies.
I actually this. This is where Bobby Kennedy's
intelligence actually comes through. It sounds
like he's doing all of the same conspiracies that
a lot of the anti-vaxxers do 5G and, you know,
government control and all these different things.
But if you listen, he's actually being really
careful because even when he talks about 5G,
he's like, they're going to be able to
harvest our data and control our behavior.
He's not actually saying the stuff the 5G people
say about, um, neurological control. He's saying
he's sort of saying like 5G has more
bandwidth and thus it'll be easier to harvest
data about our activities online and then use
that to guide us to buy certain products. Like
my point here is he seems to know that that part
is total B.S. and he's like stopping short and
using coded language. That sort of sounds like
the conspiracy, but really isn't the same thing
with cryptocurrency, like they're going to use
cryptocurrency to to kill our supply chain.
That he his virtue signaling to the conspiracy
theorists who are buying his book and making it
number one on Amazon and whatever else the
book about Dr. Fauci, if you can imagine,
but that when I see that is when I think this may
be, to some degree, a little bit of a grift. And
he may not believe everything he's saying doesn't
make it any less damaging, and we have to condemn
this disgusting stuff. Many appeals to violence
from the crowd goers. If you looked in the crowd,
the signs people were holding, there was one
that said Shoot those who tried to kidnap and
vaccinate your child. And that quotes Exodus 21
16, which reads, Quote Anyone who kidnaps someone
is to be put to death. OK, lots of Holocaust
trivialization. People with the stars of David.
Some of them, you know, some we, some call them
Jewish stars. They were all over the place. We
have one on the screen for you. And then a really
bizarre moment. Some of the musical entertainment,
there's like a sort of dance thing that was
going on. It did look like the person dancing
was having a stroke or a medical event of some
kind, like every aspect of this was insane.
Let me just play this for you if you're not
watching today, if you're just listening.
Just imagine someone appearing to have a stroke.
Unidentified: Oh, I feel so.
Speaker 1: Oh.
Unidentified: Oh, oh,
OK.
Speaker 1: Anyway, hopefully they did get
medical help for that individual if needed.
Disgusting rally and really a sign that things
are not going very well in this country. And
then we've got the other rally to talk about.